[Música]
la actualidad más destacada del
continente africano está en france24
bienvenidos a áfrica 7 días comenzamos
con los titulares el presidente francés
emmanuel macro realizó un viaje oficial
de tres días a argelia donde se reunió
con su homólogo argelino abdelmalek
debut los mandatarios abordaron los
varios temas pero el objetivo declarado
del viaje era la reconciliación y el
acercamiento entre ambos países tras
meses de crisis en angola el mp pelea el
partido en el poder desde hace casi
cinco décadas ganó las elecciones
presidenciales y legislativas tras ser
acreditado por la comisión electoral
nacional con el 51% de los votos sin
embargo las elecciones estuvieron
marcadas por una baja participación y un
resultado histórico del partido de la
oposición el unite a su candidato
adalberto costa júnior rechazó la
reelección de su rival el presidente
joao lorenzo por último hablamos de la
reanudación de los combates en la región
y tope del tigre tras la tregua de cinco
meses el gobierno del presidente de
chope había ahmad y los rebeldes del
frente de liberación de tigre se culpan
mutuamente del resurgimiento de las
hostilidades
comenzamos con el viaje del jefe de
estado francés emmanuel marco a argelia
una visita de amistad como la han
descrito tanto parís como argent emanuel
marco llegó el 25 de agosto a argelia
con una imponente delegación de 90
personas y acompañado por siete
ministros
60 años después del final de la guerra
de argelia el presidente francés y su
homólogo argelino abdelaziz debut
sellaron la reconciliación entre sus
países y proclamaron una nueva dinámica
para su relación bilateral éste
reacercamiento puso fin a meses de
tensiones y polémicas entre la ex
colonia y su ex metrópolis
las cosas empezaron bien para las
relaciones de manuel macrón con argelia
cuando estaba haciendo campaña para las
elecciones presidenciales de 2017 hizo
eco en el país africano y en francia
cuando llamo a la colonización un crimen
contra la humanidad la colonización
facilitó la colonización es parte de la
historia de francia es un crimen un
crimen contra la humanidad realmente
bárbaro es parte de un pasado con el que
tenemos que lidiar pidiendo disculpas a
las víctimas de nuestras acciones
miserias pero el año pasado las
relaciones empeoraron cuando francia
anunció que reduciría drásticamente el
número de visas otorgadas argelinos y
otros ciudadanos del norte de áfrica la
disputa se profundizó cuando macrón hizo
comentarios sobre la historia de argelia
al diario francés l monto hubo una
nación argelina antes del colonialismo
francés esa es la cuestión había otras
potencias coloniales
argel retiró a su embajador en parís y
cerró su espacio aéreo a los aviones
militares franceses a principios de 2021
makro encargó un informe sobre el
colonialismo a la recepción en argel él
no fue la esperada
con medios de comunicación y caricaturas
como esta del famoso dibujante ally
dilema destacando la ausencia de
disculpa y arrepentimiento
francia se niega a disculparse por su
pasado colonial los argelinos les
entierran el hacha de guerra macrón ha
logrado sumar algunos puntos en medio de
la disputa diplomática condenó una
sangrienta represión contra los
manifestantes argelinos por parte de la
policía en parís en 1961 calificándola
de crimen imperdonable y reconociendo
que decenas de personas habían muerto la
declaración más fuerte hasta ahora de un
político francés otra manzana de la
discordia en las relaciones bilaterales
es la devolución de los archivos
coloniales una demanda que argel repite
a menudo
abrir una nueva página en las relaciones
bilaterales con argelia esto es según
sus palabras la voluntad de emanuel
macro para ello el presidente francés
anunció la creación de una comisión de
historiadores franceses y argelinos
sobre la colonización francesa del país
norteafricano y su guerra de liberación
escuchemos no se fuma per se como
tenemos un pasado con un complejo
doloroso y a veces este pasado nos ha
impedido mirar al futuro
como pepsi
hemos decidido juntos con el presidente
t boom un paso adelante que es realmente
inédito vamos a crear una verdadera
comisión mixta de historiadores vamos a
abrir todos nuestros archivos de ambas
partes vamos a pedirle que trabaje en
todo el periodo desde el inicio de la
colonización hasta el final de la guerra
y decirle que organizaciones que era fan
de que es la primera vez desde la
independencia de argelia que se celebra
una reunión con la presencia de dos
presidentes y de todos los servicios de
seguridad interesados incluido el
ejército de ambas partes se trata de una
primicia que augura una acción conjunta
el interés de nuestro entorno
geopolítico
para comprender las claves de este viaje
de manuel marco a argelia y analizar la
complejidad de las relaciones entre
estos dos países
hablamos con sebastián busoi doctor en
ciencias políticas y especialista de las
relaciones euro árabes
durante 60 años las relaciones entre
francia y esa antigua colonia geli han
sido complicadas tortuosa si yo diría
unas relaciones de acordeón desde hace
seis décadas existe una verdadera
dificultad para que parís y argel tengan
una relación normalizada algunos países
como el reino unido por ejemplo
probablemente tengan por la propia
naturaleza de la relación que tenían con
sus antiguas colonias y protectorados
relaciones un poco más fáciles estoy
pensando en el programa online en
particular para con votar a los que
conocen las fotos luego dejan sí
en cuanto a francia la gran tragedia es
argelia porque fue una colonización que
de los 132 años porque la guerra de
descolonización en tolerancia y argelia
duró más que la segunda guerra mundial
lo que significa que entre 1954 y 1962
entre los dos países en este caso
francia y lo que él ve no sería argelia
la situación fue extremadamente
complicada y la violencia terrible así
que tuvimos un conflicto que además está
en la base misma del régimen francés que
es hoy la quinta república
[Música]
salieri en torso con lado tenemos una
francia que se construyó tras el final
de la guerra de argelia en 1954 1962 y
por otro lado una argelia que se
independizó a partir de 1962 y que
durante 60 años año tras año intentó
construirse y estructurarse
desarrollarse con punto positivos y
negativos
bueno o malo
con cada nuevo presidente cada nuevo
gobierno francés suele haber tensiones
que tienen que ver sobre todo con la
historia porque como conciliar memorias
analizadas también hay tensiones
económicas porque francia tiene
intereses en argelia al igual que en
otros países especialmente a través del
gas argelino y luego en una relación que
ya no es paternalista pero que puede
plantear un problema entre una francia
democrática y un régimen argelino que
durante 60 años ha sido de todo menos
eso e incluso desde la caída del régimen
del presidente abdelaziz buteflika
además de la cuestión de la
reconciliación y de la memoria este
viaje tenía sobre todo una gran
importancia económica en el contexto de
la crisis energética mundial por la de
ucrania dada la voluntad de la unión
europea de abandonar la dependencia del
gas ruso el gas argelino cobra
relevancia particular para francia y
discusiones sobre la posibilidad de
acelerar el suministro de gas se están
llevando a cabo
cuando un presidente francés tiene
argelia hay que andar con pies de plomo
los argelinos no se engañan se preguntan
por qué francia viene en este momento no
pueden evitar establecer un vínculo
entre la crisis energética realmente
nada a la guerra democracia y el hecho
de que argelia tenga un activo
desgraciadamente no creo que tenga 50
activos por el momento y por razones
históricas y políticas ligadas al poder
argelino pero tiene la renta petrolera
los hidrocarburos hoy el gas
ya él hay digamos la onpe solía haber
sido que habló de ayudas a los argelinos
cuando tienen un presidente francés que
viene argelia en este contexto no se
engañan y saben muy bien que el poder
francés podrá venir a argelia y dejar de
lado todas las críticas que ellos mismos
hacen gentes falta de democracia
problemas de derechos humanos monde de
monjas y hablen de duatlón faith dijera
que la tradición familiar activismo del
giradas que es el movimiento de protesta
que le lleva a derrocar al régimen
dentífrica actualmente poca libertad
incluso menos que al final de los años
de buteflika con una situación de
libertad de prensa que ahora es casi
nula los angelinos no son ingenuos
cuando se tiene elementos del lenguaje
que explican que francia viene por
razones de reconciliación histórica para
discutir esta historia de este pasado
que no pasa como se dice el pueblo
argelino no se engaña del todo recuerdo
que manel macrón vino con 90 personas
incluyendo la presidenta del grupo
energético francés
que es una persona clave hoy en día la
presión y el suministro de electricidad
y gas
cambiamos de tema y vamos a angola donde
el partido gobernante el mp pelea ha
ganado las elecciones presidenciales con
el 51% de los votos según los resultados
oficiales publicados por la comisión
electoral nacional por lo tanto el
presidente joão lorenzo ha sido
reelegido tras unas elecciones marcadas
por una baja participación y acusaciones
de fraude
aunque el mtl as sigue en el poder ha
obtenido su resultado más bajo desde el
final de la guerra civil en 2002 en las
anteriores elecciones en 2017 obtuvo más
del 61 por ciento de los votos diez
puntos más que en estos últimos comicios
además según la comisión electoral
angoleña los habitantes de la capital
luanda han votado masivamente aún y está
el partido de la oposición de hecho el
candidato de unitat adalberto costa
júnior rechazó la evitar la victoria del
mp
y denuncio discrepancias entre los
resultados oficiales y el recuento
realizado por su propio partido el
opositor pidió un nuevo recuento por
parte de una comisión independiente
podría ser el fin de la tregua anunciada
hace cinco meses en etiopía el miércoles
24 de agosto en las afueras de la
provincia de tigre los insurgentes del
frente de liberación popular de tigre se
enfrentaron en violentos combates con
las fuerzas federales y chupes estos
acontecimientos hacen temer el regreso
de la guerra sin embargo no se conocen
las causas de este nuevo brote de
violencia y ambos ejércitos se culpan
mutuamente de romper el alto el fuego
las operaciones militares se desarrollan
en varios frentes los primeros
enfrentamientos tuvieron lugar en torno
a raya un territorio disputado en el
extremo sur de chigre donde se concentra
la mayor parte de los combates sin
embargo las fuerzas y nash también
habrían intervenido en la región de afar
al este del país el oeste de chigre es
también uno de los principales puntos de
disputa en el conflicto entre el estado
de chope y los insurgentes
esta franja de 12.000 kilómetros
cuadrados de tierra fértil fue
anexionada a tigre en 1991 por el frente
de liberación popular de chigre al
principio de la guerra a las fuerzas de
la región de amara que la reclaman la
conquistaron y desde entonces según el
secretario de estado estadounidense
anthony blinken practican una política
de limpieza étnica contra los y nos así
termina el programa de esta semana pero
quédense con nosotros porque la
actualidad internacional continúa en
france24 france24 puntocom
[Música]